thank you alejandro we are indeed with
the man of the hour here in warsaw
richard rapport richard
a topsy-turvy day for you you started
off blazing hot with this game against
votashek after that you cooled off
against wesley but you finished strong
against vichy anand
describe your feelings as well as the
way you approached today's rounds
oh well
hard to
describe them actually i thought plus
one which i ended up making
before the
the day it would be a decent result
um yeah obviously if you look at the
tournament situation it was very
important to score against mishi
because he was just running away with it
but of course i feel a little bit uh
bitter about this yeah because
he's such a legend and what he has done
here i mean it's just incredible even
against me i think he had very good
winning chances okay
pretty much out of the opening but still
i mean
he should maybe he should have even had
more points than he did yeah which is
crazy
it's still competition in the end but
let's start with this moment in the
first round of today against voitasha
when you play this move bishop to d3
tell us about this one uh yeah this is a
nonsense move actually of course
um yeah i figured i played we should be
publishing c4 already yeah so i need to
play which of these three no i had
actually games here uh here in warsaw in
arabian blitz i i think i beat kiril
janko here in the last round and i think
i drew with uh locating this bishop d3
so it's uh
pretty much aiming to to get kind of a
hybrid uh
with the c3 ideas here c3
lopez yeah yeah but maybe to play
castles uh first so just in case uh you
know
andrew kim not to show cars immediately
with c3 so this is the idea now how i
came to this is that levin told me a
story
uh about uh e4c5 bishop d3 like that
this is the stupidest move and that lost
some game here with black and i thought
okay i can do better you can improve
yeah i can improve on that yes so like
knight f3 and then bishop g3 of course
i'm not
you know too proud of this but well this
is what i now over dinner last night you
told me that you have a lot of this
let's say nonsensical weapons in your
arsenal is it still the case and are you
going to employ more in the blitz even
more nonsensical ones in the blitz yeah
i hope so i mean at the end of the day
i'm trying to of course
partially hide some prep but also just
to have some fun
and i feel like you know getting some
more big positions are the way to to
have it at least for me
um yeah but actually this game against
radek turned out to be very classical so
quite smooth indeed yeah
and and then after that i played a very
normal uh line yeah king's indian and
they uh actually let's go through that
one because that one was just simply
wild yeah no i mean i think i was doing
very well okay this is a main line but i
was doing okay
really well um i think he kind of
tricked himself second try you're trying
uh yeah here uh the kings in the end did
you have any doubts about going for the
game no i play this very frequently in
shorter time control so i yeah and here
he just treat himself with a form
basically that after a4
when i do this g5 h5 i think if the pawn
was still on a3 he just goes knight h2
and i can resign but but here i have 94
and his queen is kind of trapped yeah so
i ended up having a huge advantage i
mean look at this position yeah like if
i like i just stepped upon amazing
structure yeah and then i ended up
losing is of course at the end i just
blundered in one minute even more time
on the clock yeah no i had this position
actually it's completely winning
probably um here yeah ruby seven
and then i felt like i have
visually seven is just a piece up but uh
i have okay
some kind of play but i also have bishop
six is very good and then i played queen
e6 and just completely forgot about
queen g5 and it's immediately game over
like yeah there was no way back so this
was not such a presence you just
completely uh yeah i mean g5 was a blind
spot
yeah pretty much here i mean it's
something that i brought with me from
bucharest obviously so
um but you know bishop d7 was having
just an extra piece here and i have five
minutes so at this point i didn't
feel like i was you know kind of forced
uh to blunder but this is what happens
so you know you're winning then you lose
in a couple of moves how do you recover
going into the final game against uh
vishwanathan
yeah you know i've okay i've been in
this situation a couple of times already
where kind of winning is the only result
that
matters yeah i mean of course there is
also second place in the tournament but
uh still i am right in the this game
verse double guy so i i i should try so
i played this uh
i decided to play uh another nonsense
movie four
um i don't even know what's the idea of
this one yeah i saw this fun forest
brother
four i think oh all the way back
so i saw this farm forest brothers were
doing this a4 yeah but i just don't
really understand what's the point of it
but i thought okay why not and he ended
up responding relatively sloppy of
course he i mean he's perfectly fine but
he didn't like punish me for playing e4
so we got this position which is kind of
a classical um periodic thing here but
he's got a better version obviously
because of my early a4 right here
is the knight before jumps and
everything but overall the the line is
supposed to be bad and then i did this
what everyone is doing and how they
don't equalize it's pretty impressive
because i've seen many games and i
played it black so here of course this
f4 uh
it shouldn't be played exactly for what
uh the reason for what happened in the
game but i don't know many games with
the f4 i have ideas so i went for it
navy and then i was thinking okay i'm
already worth great and then he tricked
me with this great idea bishop f5
in terms of it's very nice because he
played bishop fate first to go out of he
takes f6 uh tempo
and then rook f2 and here was critical
moment knight a4
and he should have played this three
here yeah i i clearly i think so he
should have sucked the piece and i don't
know what i would have done because if i
do something with the c pawn he will go
knight e4
and if i take the piece well dc2
takes and c4 is coming it just looks
enormous compensation did you guys get
discuss this uh position after the game
yeah he just calculated 94 ok 2 i think
but i mean i i told him that industry is
very strong but okay it's not an easy
move to make because at this point he
doesn't seem like he's in you know any
kind of danger you're changing the yeah
yeah and this is kind of an all-in-one
right because he can just lose so it's
uh i understand that maybe he didn't
feel like it was the situation was
calling for anyway afterwards i feel
like um yeah it was of course a
completely strange position as you can
see with this knight's uh absolutely on
the rim and bishop on b7 uh very strange
but i felt like okay i am
i'm not maybe worse anymore and then
later on okay i'm pawn up and i have
great structure right so i consolidated
and i
i i i mean i think i missed the win
which i couldn't believe at this point
it was indeed
completely winning yeah yeah yeah maybe
a five uh was a little no here i want to
take on before and i didn't see after
queen these three i mean look before
queen d3 is
what's happening with something to a4
like okay for maybe i think i didn't see
exactly it but and maybe seven i thought
can be six it's not so clear but worried
about the knight yeah i mean i'd be
seven i can play yeah because rugby
sevens bishop f7 checks so like this ico
so actually but
yeah like but i thought that you know
like the pawn on d6 might not
survive but obviously yeah yeah it does
so anyway but after f6 it was an
incredible moment 96 just finishes the
game
and bishop takes this ndc and i get the
same as in the game just his rook is
completely cut
and then i uh for some reason i
discovered this 96 after i took ef6 like
immediately and then of course it's not
winning that much anymore it's not the
same anymore yeah and then i was just
about to misplay in the time scramble
here and okay queen g6 was winning i
guess yes and i played queen 36 and now
yeah
i was very happy about this end game
obviously this is what
bothered him but we didn't we stopped
here like c7 but bishop c5 is extremely
strong and i can't uh maintain
the rock on f2 yeah it has to move and i
will give something about this
b6 yeah yeah yeah exactly so it's just
in chop c5 was just
blunder but okay we were short on time
and luckily for me and kate's really
unpleasant but he just blundered queen
takes f7
which i suppose surprisingly richie i
would say quite a successful trip so far
in the first three days
uh one point behind either going into
the blitz section how would you assess
your chances i think last time i was
here in warsaw i lost 160 points simply
so that speaks for itself uh maybe i'll
make it to 200 or
hopefully not yeah i will try my best
but i don't have
high expectations at this point i will
just uh you know it's blitz and uh
for me you know like everybody's five
minutes on the clock i can lose from
peace up yeah but when it comes to blitz
and you start with five minutes okay
what kind of expectations can i have
always entertaining always a pleasure to
watch your games we'll see you tomorrow
richie yeah guys
thank you christian thank you uh
richie uh